[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time
i'm rhett and i'm linked this week at
the round
table of dim lighting we're gonna we're
gonna pull back the curtain
on all of the ideas that we've had
for traditional projects i'm talking
about
scripted television uh movies
non-scripted television
animated projects we've we we
we have so many ideas that we've come up
with over the years and we've
pursued a lot of them
and some of them went a long ways but
but a lot of the
basically everything we're going to talk
about has never seen the light of day
until today and i just thought it would
be fun for us to
share with you all of these specific
ideas we've had that encapsulate
a percentage of what our collective
creative dreams are you know
well i would say a significant
percentage of time and
also of aspiration yeah you know um
and we might i don't know this may end
up being a two-part thing where we talk
a little bit more about like the
personal
like dealing with rejection we'll we'll
see how far we get into that
i think there's a whole conversation to
be had around dealing with rejection and
failure
i agree because i was actually wondering
like is this actually going to be
depressing to revisit all these ideas
that just
died on the vine or fizzled out and i i
want to keep this fun
but i do think there is a reality to
weathering a ton of rejection yeah well
and i think that
we say this a lot that
you know you may wonder sometimes i mean
there is a lot of things that you see
right you see this podcast you see good
mythical morning good mythical more
you see all the other stuff that
mythical entertainment uh puts out and
we're involved in a lot of things and
then some things you do
see like when you know the lost causes
of bleak creek or the book of
mythicality or buddy system there are
other things
throughout the years that have seen the
light of day have gone through the full
birth of the creative process and and
birthed out into the world but
when you ask yourself what do you guys
what exactly do you
do well besides the things that you see
we do
spend a very significant portion of our
time
trying to make things happen through
other avenues and i'll just
just set it up just quickly to not get
too much into this but like
okay yeah you have this youtube channel
you have this audience you have
you have people who are willing to watch
and listen to the things that you create
so
why are you spending your time trying to
make say a television show
a movie or or whatever when there's not
making it sell
yeah there's when there's no guarantee
that anybody's ever gonna see it
uh and is it do you feel inferior
because you're only making stuff
for a digital audience and you're not
being able to do the traditional thing i
mean
there's pr there's definitely a uh for
me
sort of a chip on my shoulder of not
being able to work on those things that
uh are the things that kind of i
personally enjoy a little bit more like
i
i enjoy traditional tv and movies more
than i enjoy watching youtube videos
that's just just
me personally and how i spend most of my
time being entertained
but it's less that that's a for me
that's kind of a small portion of it
and it's really more that we're
limited in the kinds of stories that we
can tell and the kinds of things that we
can explore
through the youtube medium just because
you know you have to create content
that can make a business can run a
business
and can and it can be a profitable thing
it's like we talked about for years with
buddy systems like we were glad we got
to make the opportunity we had the
opportunity to make buddy system because
we finally got paid people would
complain about why it was on youtube red
yeah everybody couldn't see it now
everybody can see it but
yeah it's free now for anyone years
later but at the time that our response
was
we couldn't make a a more ambitious
scripted project with the budgets we
were working with
without getting funding from some from
an outlet that then you'd have to you
got to pay for
and when you go through those when you
go through that process
of developing an idea and taking it out
into the traditional way you know taking
it to somebody pitching it to a network
or a streamer or whatever you um
you run up against something that's very
unusual for us like we
you know we have an idea to make this
podcast we just do it we have an idea to
make this episode of this podcast you we
just do it we just
make the decision and we just do it and
there it is distributed
to everyone right ad supported most of
the time every everything
every decision associated with mythical
morning the buck stops with us
and there's no charge there's you know
there's really no gatekeeper right i
mean sure there's
rules and regulations that you have to
abide by if you want your video to get
served up to everybody on youtube
right you cannot eat a mattress anymore
on youtube if you eat a mattress you
have to
that will get banned and you have to
just give it to the mythical society
but with everything in the traditional
space they're still
the gatekeepers because this stuff costs
so much more money to make
they've got the money they're holding
the purse strings and they control the
gate and they control who gets in the
gate and we
you know i don't know i don't even know
how i feel about some of these ideas
because we're going back
at least a decade yeah and covering uh a
lot of things that
i'm it's not like here i'll be very
clear before we get into these it's not
like
you're gonna be blown away with the
innovative
and original nature of these ideas and
be like i can't believe nobody
the thing is let him be the judge but
i'm saying that there are so
many talented people in the world trying
to get
things made and i'm not saying that
we've we've gotten
all into the deal i'm just saying it's a
difficult thing when you when you go
through the
the gatekeepers it's a difficult process
and you got to develop
you got to develop a thick skin and you
got to develop a lot of ideas i have a
working list
in front of me of what might be
20. and so i'm going to throw out
just some some working titles and see if
you can
remember these i don't think you're
going to remember all these ideas
i certainly didn't i just had to dig
them up in our google vault
but let's start with talking about today
on good mythical more
we made a decision for daniel to come in
and
you know he hadn't come in in a long
time so
you you stepped away yeah daniel stepped
in
and uh he ended up showing this sizzle
reel
for quite a bit he an animated series
that he says that he developed that okay
yet we developed an animated series and
this is one of the most recent ideas
that fizzled out you know
daniel said that you know there was a
lot of interest especially from one
network
and then as we were talking about how
like the budget and like getting into
details on
how that you know how they would fund it
and how much
then the entire team that we've been
talking to
like they i don't know they got fired
they got restructured
happens it was done away with so
everyone that we were talking to
no longer worked at the network yeah
which kind of means
the idea is dead i mean because we had
taken it out to other places and
and this was the one place that was most
interested
so we were like you know what screw it
we made this sizzle reel it's a freaking
animated
thing in in partnership with a
cartoon cartoon uh shout out to cartoon
i'm sorry i almost forgot
i didn't i didn't forget i won't forget
you cartoona
we'll work with you again but we're like
they put a lot of good work into this it
was all speculative
everybody spent a little money nobody
made anything like let's at least
show it to you guys so that's what we're
like screw it let's do it
and now let's talk about it it's called
unattended baggage
we're like let's put cotton candy randy
daniel
in a in an environment
uh let's put them in an airport where
they work we just thought it would be
funny to like
even though you could go anywhere in the
world of cartoon animation
we just thought it was ironic to like
yeah it was the built-in irony pin them
down
in the one place that everybody wants to
escape from and that's an airport
there's lots of different places you can
work there's lots of like workplace
dynamics there
so we started to build out one of those
kind of things it was based on the one
the one time that i think daniel and
cotton candy randy got together
in a in either a gmm or a gm more
episode and we were like
you know these guys are so otherworldly
i mean literally in some ways that this
seems like the perfect thing to to put
them together an animated show
and you know but the idea was okay so
you got me
as daniel you you got jordan as cotton
candy randy
and then well i should be in it too you
know this needs to be a trio
and so the original idea basically just
had
you as kind of a grounded character i
don't know exactly
your name may have already been leroy
but you were essentially link and you
were using your regular voice and we
actually
did a whole like with that in in fact
the
uh the animation the animation and
everything was originally
just you talking in your normal voice
then we got we got to get a funnier
voice and then we're like
that character needs to be funny too
much opportunity for this character to
be funny and so then you basically ended
up
kind of doing your forest patrol voice
right
uh it's essentially the same guy because
as much as people
want force patrol to come back like
it it costs a lot of money to animate
and we couldn't we we just can't justify
or or support that
just online again you make us like i'll
just take that characterization
i'll bake it into this character and
we'll see what happens
i thought it was i thought it was a big
improvement
um i got to say i mean are we
listen i don't want this to be a downer
but i am going to just be honest with
you
as we revisit these ideas and
i still think that uh i still think that
unattended baggage could be a great show
especially in the way that we kind of
developed
the pitch even after we developed the
scissor reel yeah but i gotta say
and we should talk about i want to say
what that is because i think that's
the strength of the show is actually not
in the sizzle reel because
we got going we wrote something it was
animated and then we were like
you know what and it was called fairview
because
fairview international was the name of
the airport yeah but then we started to
really dig into the characters and we
were like
i think there's something about dealing
with masculinity
toxic masculinity um stereotypical
masculinity
and guys getting in touch with their
feelings and their
their their trauma potentially well
every now and then every one of the
characters ended up it was very clear
every one of the characters had
some some baggage had some psychological
things some trauma in their background
that really contributed to who they were
and actually contributed to who they
were and what made them
funny so let's play with that with
and like within their world
let's let's actually grapple with
therapy and what it like their need for
therapy informally
informally um through other characters
and let's then we change the title to
unattended baggage
and every every episode was going to be
or
not necessarily every episode but in
many different
episodes if it was going to be often a
device that we were going to use was
going to be a flashback to the
childhoods
of each one of our main three characters
so that you kind of explore the
relationship with them and their parents
and then how they're
as adults having never properly dealt
with all their unintended baggage as
kids
are kind of working that out in hell you
know two hilarious
ends right as adults so that's what the
show became it doesn't really it's not
really captured in the reel
the sizzle reel was like a section of
the pilot that's what we were excited
about though was
was when you when we got into the
exploring the
guys and therapy of it all yeah i have
absolutely no idea i'm sure we'll see
in the comments how people will respond
to the
uh showing that to them you know i think
people
i think we did it in a way that was a
bit confusing because it's like is this
real was this real
you know yeah yeah that was fun have
they really committed this much to this
bit
to show this i don't know how you know i
think the show
would be much better than the than the
sizzle reel indicates
but you know you be the judge of what
you think this is we listen
if those people weren't laid off we'd be
making the show
because i also think that they
understood what we were doing and how it
had kind of
updated and um i have mixed feelings
about that one because i
still feel like there's a viable show
there i just don't feel like
we executed it we executed the pitch
that great and then of course
things outside of our control caused it
to fall through okay so that was like
one of the more recent ideas i want to
go back to one of the
first ideas that we came up with now
we're going back to the online nation
days so we were coming out here we were
hosting the show
you know basically beginning to host it
as it was already beginning to be
canceled
um one of the producers on the show paul
was basically he became our de facto
manager because
every time we came out here we were like
okay we we got ideas we got to get
something else we got
we got stuff we want to do paul
cockerell
um you know he was basically the guy
who discovered paulie shore the reason
why
paulie shore was the vj personality that
he was on
mtv was because paul was because of paul
and he was instrumental in basically
establishing
uh los angeles as a as a home for mtv is
right
from from new york right because it had
basically been a new york thing yeah he
was
he was the first la guy and then the
other producer
of online nation was david hurwitz
who was an executive producer on fear
factor
back in the day you know years earlier
somebody who famously said to us while
we were hosting online nation
more energy more energy that's all you
would say
more energy but paul was more hands-on
as an inside joke so paul became our de
facto manager so he was the one that we
were talking to about all these ideas
scripted and non-scripted and he was
like well
do you was like yeah we get we can we
got a scripted idea we can write a pilot
and we went back home and we wrote
what eventually became we called
legitimate
so you're so that was before the reality
ideas or
and so i think it i think at the same
time
because because i've got the script on
my computer and it says copyright 2012.
mm-hmm i think at the same time we were
also developing non-scripted
ideas we had two of those but we sh but
we
shot sizzle reels for those those were
before because
we still lived in north carolina because
i remember being in the lilington
going in around lillington shooting some
of that stuff that's where we were when
we wrote
we started writing legitimate too so
they were happening at the same time
okay so i guess it was just 2012 as a
win we can talk about the non-scripted
stuff we had this idea for
um a reality show kind of like dirty
jobs but
instead of micro it's the two of us
going around to like
redneck what i mean what i call
redneck hobbies redneck pastimes
yeah lawnmower racing uh noodling that's
where you like you put your you dig your
hand down into a river and you get a
catfish to eat your hand
like we were gonna go do these things
and we were like hey
we know enough of these people we can we
can put something on tape
so to speak that can sell this idea
because it's like hey we're
we still can tap into that good old boy
nature you know we still
live here in harnett county and
my dad knew all of these guys
who participated in competitive
lawnmower racing
right and so we went out there we got
permission to film the whole thing
and then we started interviewing guys
and like i mean there's some funny
moments
when we were in we participated in the
lawnmower race
these are not normal lawn mowers they're
like drag racing versions of lawn mowers
and and they they pull a sled
in a straight line and whoever can get
the furthest the fastest wins and yeah
we talked a guy into letting us
ride his uh lawnmower
in the competition and we made complete
fools out of ourselves and it was
perfect
it was funny in our mind it was funny i
mean again i can't we called it good old
boy good old boys i can't help but be
the
the you know the 10-year later producer
and be like
oh the fatal flaw with this idea was
that we assumed
that we had the right in other words
like okay
dirty jobs of micro kind of make sense a
little bit like it started as like he
was like this guy doing this bit on the
radio
and he's this older guy that's like
highlighting these people
in america we were just like two
dumbasses who were like
a little bit crunch country a little bit
rock and roll who thought we could go
and just
hang out with rednecks and have fun and
while i do think it would have been a
funny show
people were at the time we're looking
for like what's your end like why you
guys for this thing and so it just kind
of died
on the vine like maybe it should be
larry the cable guy that's kind of what
you're saying
yeah but i mean for the for the video
version of this thing we can we can show
you a clip we'll dig up the archives
at the same time we developed another
pitch because we told paul
well you know we also have engineering
degrees we can you know we're smart guys
um we developed a pitch called this or
that
now this was a good idea we couldn't
call it would you rather because would
you rather was a
trademarked or whatever it is as a game
we looked into licensing it
like paul looked into that but like they
wouldn't have any part of it so we just
changed it to this or that
but it was a as far as i can remember
we we would pick two things what was it
would you rather scenario it was would
you rather
that could actually be carried out and
we would both do one
side of the thing and come to the
decision of which one was the actual
correct answer we would actually
definitively know because we've
experienced both
sides of it so like we shot a reel for
that too would you rather
there was a fire hose involved in one
scene i think it was would you rather
be pelted
with a full blast of a fire hose
for x number of minutes or
have to walk around town in an
entire day completely soaked
and so then we cut to a shot of
one of us dousing ourselves completely
with water from head to toe like boots
filling up with water
in the walmart parking lot and then
walking into walmart
so you get an idea of okay cameron's
gonna follow around one of us who is
like
constantly soaking himself and trying to
conduct
normal life maybe get a mortgage i don't
know
so it's it's a bit spitty kind of
sketchy
but then we also cut to the other person
who was standing
in front of a a fireman with a hose
and he started blasting us with water it
was joey smith yeah because
i mean back in harley county
serving with the lillington volunteer
fire department and had access to a fire
hose
and uh did we actually get sprayed with
the fire hose that day
or did we just make it look like it was
about to happen i can't remember i'll
have to look at the footage
i'm pretty sure that we were just far
enough away
that it wasn't crazy that it wasn't that
crazy but i might just be making it up
in my mind
the footage will tell that particular
example that we used
for the for the pitch is not great but
the show
still there were other examples that
make sense too i think we had two more
sets of examples but that's a fun idea
yeah i think we revisited it a few times
as a maybe as a web series
as a web series uh i'm surprised we
didn't pull the trigger on it because
it's almost something that we could do
well we ended up doing would you rather
as a gmm
segment and that's when a baby birded
things into your mouth yeah
we just made a the smaller more
producible version of that
the last thing i remember we did with
paul was
instead of us coming out to l.a one time
he said that he was coming out to
maryland for something
and he said you boys need to drive up
because the discovery channel
headquarters
silver springs is in silver springs
maryland right on the edge of washington
dc
that's where you had to meet with
talent uh the development for if you
wanted to have a show on the discovery
channel and
you know but we really thought because
we had engineering degrees
we should be able to come up with an
idea did we
did we take this or that to them i think
we took a couple of other ideas
but i remember it being all the ideas it
was more of a meet and greet meeting too
where it was like yeah you we should
work together
sometimes it's just it's not about the
pitches it's just about
getting to know like i remember that
i remember an idea that we pitched to
them and i still i'm afraid
i'm afraid to i still think this is a
great idea for a show
it was our answer to a man on the street
show it was our answer to cash cap
and it was called guesstimators oh
well yeah because we well we brought
that back as a magic number we'll talk
about it later but do you remember
so the guesstimators idea which yes we
brought back is a different idea that
was more contained but the original
idea yeah for guesstimators was that we
would be
and this is sort of based on the the you
know the thing that we do
on gmm sometimes which is we try to
guess a number of something but this was
like
you're on the street let's say one
episode takes place in new york city and
so
we walk up to somebody on the street and
we say
sir right there you see the empire state
building
how many windows individual windows do
you think
are on the empire state building if you
can get within
10 you're gonna win a thousand dollars
right now or something like that
and so then it would be like you do
would guess and he would be wrong or
he'd be right
but then there would be this like
graphical sort of like animated thing
where it would be like here's the empire
state building and all of a sudden
like animated like overlay on it would
show you like there's this many windows
and they're made out of this and they're
this big and they attach in this way
yeah
you'd learn all this you'd learn all
this stuff through the animation
right and uh but you would also get it
if you're one of those people
like you that really loves to
guesstimate things and is actually
really good at it
we thought that was another part of it
was like you you've always done that
you've always made me guess things just
so i look like an idiot
right so it's like that foil and this is
part of our pitch it's like hey you're
really good at estimating
and i suck at it so maybe there's a way
to play into that for some comedy
right so yeah that was uh that was that
was a fun idea
i mean you have to believe in the ideas
to really pitch them
yeah you know in the moment especially
but then it's like
it's you can question them later so we
get we've got more of these
but first i just want to
tell you to buy this mug no no no you
can't buy that mug but it's the t-shirt
it's not the mug
this t-shirt very special t-shirt it is
uh only available to third degree
members of the mythical society
as is the album that it references of
course this is rent link sing lionel
this is the picture on the front of the
album in which we which is the latest
collectible item that you can get as a
third degree member of the mythical
society
but if you want the t-shirt that is
associated with it that comes with our
signatures i mean this is a printed
signature i'm not going to lie to you we
didn't sign every single one of these
you have to be a third degree member to
be eligible to purchase it
so it's a little bit different we
haven't done this exclusive purchasable
item within the context of the mythical
society so
super special super exclusive limited
time
mythical society.com well go to
mythical.com to buy this shirt no but
it's only available for third degree
members oh you see it but you get like a
code or something
i don't know yeah yeah you get a code
let's just say that i don't know you'll
figure it out if you're a society member
you'll be able to buy it at mythical.com
okay legitimate is the pilot
that we conceptualized and wrote at the
same time and i swear i mean
the first working title of legitimate
was
musical therapy musical therapy because
we were like hey we're musical comedians
we can write funny songs i bet you we
can bake that into
a television show and then paul was like
yeah yeah yeah do that
it's like we'll call it musical therapy
he was like yeah where and
you were like let's write it so we went
back to our cave and then we
conceptualized this thing
and eventually we changed the name of it
because the name of the town was
legitimate
and so we're like oh that's a cool name
for and also so you know the prim the
premise of the show is that
you've got two guys he usually starts
with two guys
for obvious reasons who uh have been
in los angeles doing the musical therapy
thing like actually operating a musical
therapy
business and then there was an accident
someone accidentally
passed away when they were participating
in the musical therapy in the hospital
that's the opening scene the funny thing
is is it's not the opening scene in this
version that i've got
uh got a few versions that i found on
dropbox
this is what is called a legitimate
pilot draft three
okay and it starts
with us in our office in legitimate
which you're but you're right that
in my recollection the first the opening
scene
was in the hospital in los angeles and
we had this dream for
um jack black to play the patient who
dies in the very opening scene yeah
because we were meeting with production
companies and we met with
yeah we partnered with somebody and we
met with jack black's production company
jack black was not there no he probably
never heard about it his development
person was there and we
you know we gave the whole pitch and we
were like all right opening scene
you got this guy who um
he's he's he's in his hospital bed and
then his musical therapists come in and
they start playing him a song
and we actually wrote the song because
we sing the song in the pitch
and then because we sang the song in the
pitch like you brought your guitar and
we started singing the song and it
sounded good i mean
and he gets so into it that he's in the
hospital because of a heart condition
and then he gets so into the performance
in the opening scene that he has a heart
attack and dies
and so we get sued for malpractice we
lose our los angeles practice and we
have to go back to our hometown of
legitimate north carolina which is not a
real town
but is basically a bowie's creek type
well a little bit bigger than boys creek
maybe a few quite situation
and then the show is about these two
guys who've kind of gone off to la and
become a little bit latified but then
failed and failed and then had to kind
of come back home with their tail
between their legs
and no one understands what musical
therapy is yeah and then try to do
something that's very very
la in a place that's very very not la so
they still try to be musical therapists
but the real story oh man it's been so
long the real story is more about like
me reconnecting with my ex girl or my
character reconnecting with his
ex-girlfriend who's now
pregnant by his father well that's a
spoiler alert yeah that's the
the very last so well so you get
introduced sorry don't spoil it you get
introduced
to uh your old your ex-girlfriend and
she's pregnant and it's awkward and
you're kind of like uh
you know like you're still single but
you've got you but you're kind of
interested
you were interested in her and kind of
this long lost love kind of thing
and then when you come back she's
pregnant and this is news to you
and then and then the final scene of the
pilot that it reveals that
she's pregnant with your father's baby
which then sets up the rest of the
season and there's i still love that
there's another character t-bird
that a version of t-birch made his way
into
the lost causes of bleak creek yeah
travis is a t-birds character yeah that
kind of so
these things come back to us but there's
this whole thing about like raiding a
sperm bank
that's that's the i mean i think we
should take this script and that's
my i think that's my dad in the in the
thing he has been
right he's been donating his uh
he's been donating his he's been getting
a lot of money for donating sperm
and t-birch helps us break into a sperm
bank so we
i don't remember why but i think we
should take this script
and we should post it on the mythical
society well let me read it one more
time
don't you think all right read it one
more time let me
it's i'm sure that the writing is not
great just just just between you and
us i'm sure the writing is not not not
like all of a sudden our writing is good
now i'm just or
i'm just saying we've it's been ten
years is a long time
um all right so i'm gonna do do you want
to go with some scripted ideas let's go
with some scripted ideas and come back
to non-scripted do you remember any of
these because i'm moving on
so all right and these will kind of be
out of order these are from 2018
we kind of set we go through these like
sort of development periods we go
through
periods where we have a little bit of
time we sit down and we come up with
like
four six ten ideas we bounce them off
stevie
sometimes some other people we figure
out what we're most excited about and
then when like
our agents set up meetings so you're
jumping all the way to 2018 did you skip
a bunch of stuff
i'm gonna go back i'm gonna i'm gonna
skip around yeah okay do
you remember um t minus mars
very well yeah all right what do you
remember about it this was a a
community of people who were preparing
to be
the first colony on mars and in
preparation to become
the colony on mars they had to live in
this basically this replica biosphere
on earth for an indefinite amount of
time
as sort of a test like a psychological
test
and a sort of uh how well can they get
along with each other
in this space on earth and it was paid
for by an eccentric billionaire
a woman who had gotten all her money by
inventing
some ridiculous uh like some kind of
weird shoe
what was it that she had invented she'd
invented a weird shoe
which incidentally the flip oh it's a
flip-flop that doesn't make a flip sound
doesn't make a flop sound
and uh yeah and so she's a billionaire
because of that and anyway they
it's this it's essentially an ensemble
cast sort of like you know your
typical uh you know half hour comedy
like the office or whatever but there's
no one inside this thing
it's like that mars moo uh show that
came out that had
uh tim hydeker and
i never watched that i watched the pilot
and it was it was similar it's like
there was
basically it was a lot of people
thinking about like mars
colonization and coming up with tv ideas
and were they on mars in the show are
they on earth
they were on earth and they were they
were trying to get there but they were a
bunch of misfits
yeah same i mean similar same idea and
to be clear i'm not saying
it was uh what do you call it multiple
multiple discovery
is what they call that in in in science
it happens all the time in entertainment
where
oh yeah two people come up with ideas
um at the same time
we were we put that one out there we
also put beef queen out there
beef queen is the this
of a family uh fast food owned franchise
sort of like an in and out situation
and the father is basically
suffering from dementia the guy who
found it sort of like a ray kroc kind of
thing like he founded this incredibly
successful restaurant and he's on the
way out and his two daughters
he's handing him the business over to
his two daughters and he's got one
daughter who's like the older daughter
and she's like totally committed to the
vision and has
been on board the entire time and you've
got the flaky
younger sister who's sort of like this
new age hippie who
kind of stands for all this stuff that
is diametrically opposed to
be selling hamburgers to everyone and
what that does to the world
yeah and the husbands of each one of
these so
i played i was going to play
the husband hendrix maze hendrix who was
sort of the hippie
husband abstract artist who married
denise several years ago
given his obsession with social and
environmental justice he convinced the
sisters to start love queen shortly
after joining the family
he's the polar opposite of the typical
beef queen customer and to be clear love
queen
is the philanthropic arm of beef queen
which is basically designed to offset
all the harm that beef queen does to the
world
love queen is kind of trying to like
minimize the carbon footprint or offset
the carbon footprint right so that's the
thing
that maze is in charge of yeah but then
your character
kevin picarcharsky picarcharsky
two cars read his destiny danielle's
brand new husband he's a small town guy
who was up until recently
just a manager of a beef queen in ohio
now to be clear
we're talking about the daughter the
super ambitious daughter who's the real
sort of business mind
she's so focused on beef queen
that she doesn't have time for a someone
who's going to like challenge her
so she she she needs somebody who's
going to do exactly what she says
yeah so it just gets this danielle fell
in love with him on an episode of
undercover boss
she also became an unintentional meme
for complimenting kevin on how he
handled his meat while on the show
right kevin is remarkably naive about
everything outside of the small town
where he grew up and worked
until marrying danielle he's
continuously amazed by life in the big
city
like he's not like he hasn't seen an
escalator before like everything is new
to him
yeah yeah he's incredibly ignorant of
all things that maze holds
sacred which infuriates maize danielle
thought it would be a good idea to have
kevin run love queen along with maize
hoping that his beef queen loyalty and
apolitical nature would
help take some of the edge off of love
queen's more questionable
operations right so you've got this
basically sort of
conservative guy that hasn't experienced
a lot of the world and then you've got
this over-the-top
hippie left winger and they have to work
together
kind of in the context of this sub
organization that's in the that's the
bigger context it's this giant
fast food chain i still like this this
is a fun
idea um we pitched this idea to adam
mckay's company
i mean oh yeah we did adam you know we
go into adam mckay's office
he wasn't there he wasn't there but his
business partner and development guy i'm
sorry i can't remember his name but
was there and we had a good conversation
it's not they
just to be clear because i don't want
people to be here just
oh god real quick let me just i want to
say this real quick okay
sometimes we go out on a limb and we
talk about sort of things like this
pr you know not private but things that
you didn't know about before
like a prime example is
several years ago when i auditioned to
be face for guardians of the galaxy
right
and i told the story of the audition and
all i said
was that the audition went well and that
there was like a second level of
interest like
it wasn't like they just you know i i
heard
through the grapevine that they and the
director james gunn
liked the audition and that's all i said
right and we thought it would be cool to
tell you that
that got turned into someone one of you
going on to james gunn's instagram
page and commenting on a completely
unrelated post
and asking him the question he was
answering questions on twitter now we
don't know who made the post so it was
on instagram
if you're starting to get embarrassed
right now we do not know who you are we
didn't pay attention
and we're not holding it against you and
we don't remember your name but
you sweat it but what you said was is it
true
that rhett mclaughlin was the first
choice for taser face
at which point james gunn literally
responds to that in the comments and
says
no chris sullivan was always our first
choice although
i like that guy or whatever he so he
acknowledged that
so it seemed like you were going to you
were like saying publicly that like
you turned down the bro so now james
gunn thinks that i think that i was the
first choice for taser face
that's not what i said and i regret even
saying anything about it but now you're
talking about us going into
so don't tweet adam mckay thinking
you're doing us any favors by saying you
should really do that beef queen idea he
won't know what the hell you're talking
about and it'll embarrass us
so listen just keep it to yourself and
okay
and if you want to know what it feels
like to be our children this is how we
talk to them sometimes
don't embarrass me in public okay
and uh if you want to know how my kids
have to treat me sometimes they also
tell me hey don't embarrass me in public
sometimes yeah i still like that idea i
still like yeah it was a it was a fun
idea
i mean we you know you go around you
meet with people who you think can
produce this thing
uh i'm not gonna mention the other
people because now i'm regretting it
and also we didn't we just did a a
write-up for this we didn't write the
pilot
and also and this is something you know
this is something that we continue to
debate amongst ourselves and that is
do we are we just writing this
in making this or producing this are we
doing that and
also starring in it obviously with buddy
system yeah we did we did all that
but i don't know the more time that
passes the more convinced we become that
like
you kind of have to i don't know you
kind of have to make a choice so
i don't know if you're going to get into
any ideas it's more recent that we've
developed ideas that don't have us being
the two
it doesn't start with two guys here's
something you won't remember i'll just
read the one
do you remember a show called sos uh
that was just a log line
um just begin to read it and then i'll
remember it two brothers-in-law
who happen to deeply hate one another
find themselves
oh um stranded on an island marooned on
an island after going overboard during a
flight on a family cruise vacation
the need to overcome their differences
to survive on this island full of
secrets
think lost meets last man on earth
that was it yeah and it was going to be
like a surreal a surreal comedy
sunshine ranch oh um uh
oh you gotta give me the first bit
people
come to sunshine sunshine ranch sun sign
to deal with addiction but
not the typical vices of drugs sex and
alcohol
no the staff of sunshine ranch
specialize
in oh gosh i can't remember that strange
addictions
there's a woman who's attracted to
inflatable furniture there's even a dude
who's addicted to staring at his legs in
a mirror
kurt finds himself sent to sunshine
ranch after a family intervention over
his addiction to new car smell
which has left him deeply in debt this
is a dumb idea
he insists he's normal ensemble cast run
link are patients
or potentially patient staff that's a
dumb idea maybe
that's potentially offensive yeah it's
also like insensitive wrong-minded yeah
yep not proud of that making fun of
people's addictions i didn't read it
to myself before i read it it's good we
go into places and you just
you got to just let the ideas flow
sometimes opinionated
this one starts off rhett and link bond
i don't even know if this is scripted
rhett and link bond over pointing out
what's annoying about other people
i think that's just a statement that's a
backstory statement
this gives them the idea to start a
business which offers a very simple yet
specialized service i remember this
spend one hour with someone and then
tell them everything about them that's
annoying
can their friendship and business
partnership withstand one another's
razor sharp criticism we
so the premise for this and again this
is not a developed show idea but it is
based on the idea
that uh sometimes
this i mean this may look make us look
like [ __ ] and we're not [ __ ] to
people directly let me just be honest
about that or be you know just get that
out there but you know
especially back you know before the
pandemic when we actually would go to
social functions and meet new people you
know sometimes you'll like go to a party
and you'll meet somebody
and then we'll begin to have a
conversation after the party and be like
did you meet that guy
did you meet curt right and it's like uh
oh yeah and did you notice the thing he
did with did you notice the thing that
he did with his
so it's more observational humor but
yeah it's like
we like picking people apart and we also
knew that like if you took people who
did that to an extreme they would be
[ __ ]
and they probably couldn't live with
each other that's a good thing and let
me be clear i'm not
so kurt sutter is a friend i'm not
talking about kurt sutter i it's
i just use the name kurt it's like that
i think kurt was in the last pitch
there's a
there's nothing annoying about there's
nothing annoying about kurt all right
let me go to feature ideas um
okay the beast is real
okay i definitely remember this one i
mean this one says 2018
uh two friends are deep in the
wilderness dead set on locating a fabled
forest beast think bigfoot but cooler
but it turns out that they're escapees
from a mental hospital what we can't do
that
but hold on it's just to be clear like
it's
this is this is one of those and i do
question whether or not you can do this
anymore and i realize there's only 2018
that we came up with this idea
but the idea was that you've got someone
that is wrongfully
has been wrongfully uh committed
yeah i mean even we've both been
watching the leftovers and there's a lot
of that going on there there's a guy in
them
and it's where your dad's in the
mentality the question is it's sort of
blurring the idea between
you know reality and fantasy and they're
like is this person
like certifiable or or do you know
because right now it raises the question
yeah you say that you've had an
experience with the sasquatch
you know most people think that you're
not there's something not quite right
with you yeah and so but
these guys have this commitment to
finding this thing and there's a
their resident psychiatrist julie who
has played along with the guy's
imaginative ideas for years
joins their journey in an effort to
bring them home safely and unharmed
when julie is accidentally shot by one
of them
they must abandon their journey and
bring her to safety
things are complicated when they
actually encounter the beast itself
boom spoiler alert tone is comedic
but gripping and real kind like swiss
army man meets oh brother where art thou
meets deliverance
this i mean again this was what it's
just an idea you know it's an idea
it hasn't it hasn't been developed we
didn't pitch that to anybody no i i
don't think we
yeah it's got some flaws charlie horse
saves the world
this is a this was 2018 but this is
something that was percolating
for many years i the way i remember this
idea starting and i'm not i'll let you
share the idea as much as you remember
it or i can read it
um we we had these meetings with
production companies
and i think paul set this up way back
then where we would go
and we would just have meet and greet
meetings
and say yeah we've got a bunch of ideas
but this is more about just knowing that
we're here now
look at us rent link we're in la general
meetings generals
they call it yeah you would you go in
you sit in the lobby and
somebody at it behind a desk would like
say would you like some coffee or tea
while you wait up to
40 minutes to go back for this general
meeting that is
no one's priority and we say sure the
best thing about it is getting the
drinks and sitting there and like
looking at the posters on the wall of
all the stuff they've made
and we didn't like we still don't like
general meetings right
because we're like why are we talking
about things in general when we can talk
about this a specific idea
yeah and so we just kind of lost our
appetite because we were like if we were
having a general meeting with somebody
we'd be it's like well okay what are we
going to do together we had a few and
people would say do you have any ideas
and we'd be like
yeah we're working on a bunch of stuff
we can come back to you and it felt like
we were like keeping things secret but
we really didn't have any ideas
so what we ended up doing that day is we
were looking at the posters in the lobby
which
you know signified the movies that this
particular outfit had worked on
and we began to pick up on a theme from
some of the movies they worked on and we
were like
comedy sci-fi let's take some of the
genres that we're seeing
represented in their repertoire and
let's develop an idea
i still right now in right now sitting
on this on this
couch and then when we went into the
room and they asked us do you have any
ideas
this idea five minutes before the
meeting then we go into the meeting and
when they say you got any ideas we
pitched the idea and they liked it
and they weren't they were like okay
once you once you start writing that
come back to us which is
you know now we know his code for i'll
believe it when i see it okay i'll see
if i can what i can remember about this
idea but i got to tell you
i still feel like this is a viable idea
it's just a little bit too big budget
for us at this point this might be as
if we actually make a movie and people
like it but
charlie horse is a band a band that was
popular in the
70s or 80s southern rock band of the 80s
kind of thing i mean we were thinking
alabama
meets countries meets almond brothers in
the 80s and charlie horse is a really
good
name for a band yeah because if you
punch somebody in the leg they get a
charlie horse
but the the premise was that nasa had
been you know how nasa will
like broadcast or at least the seti
institute will like broadcast
radio signals into the universe to try
to say hey here we are
and presumably there's music i know for
a fact that in some
instances there's been music that's been
broadcast and so the premise of
charlie horse saves the world is that
their music has been broadcast since the
70s
into space 80s since the 80s into space
and then now
the president in the 80s the president
chose to include their double platinum
album black snake
fever in a radio broadcast that was
transmitted into deep space
it turns out the broadcast created some
extraterrestrial super fans
yeah you remember anything else i i
remember that the aliens come to earth
over 30 years later their mission is to
find charlotte
which incidentally has disbanded by this
point and so
charlie or whoever's in charge of
charlie horse probably a horse
has to go and assemble try to assemble
the ban and get them back together so
they can
save the world yeah it's not an easy
task but once the boys get back together
their new songs are so bad that they
offend their alien visitors who vowed to
destroy the planet
can charlie horse pull off one last
explosive performance and save earth
i love this idea yeah yeah because
there's there's definitely something to
do because if you look at
80s era alabama they're just such
ridiculous characters you can see
playing all of them yeah well and we
were like we can confidently play these
characters but we can also
get some more seasoned comedic actors to
sort of take the lead on this one
and be open to be part of an ensemble
what about catch and release
uh that is a mockumentary
about uh a famous
fisherman who runs a
uh like a like a fishing channel
and there's a new like hot shot well i
can't remember exactly what happens but
it's basically a
documentary about professional bass
fishermen early 90s
skeet nixon and you're hey it's good you
you got a good memory for this stuff
i mean when you come up with it it's
easy to remember
set in the early 90s skeet nixon and
dale dance
are the most popular professional
anglers in the world yeah they are
which doesn't mean much they each have
prime time shows on fish tv
and they're mortal enemies that have
been locked in a bitter competition for
over a decade
when fish tvs ratings plummet due to the
lack of interest in professional fishing
a smooth talking reality tv producer
talks skeet and dale into moving into a
house together yeah
starting a reality tv that's so good
this is still a good idea
we could make this with no money this is
a low budget idea for real this is not
charlie horse saves the world this is
something that we could make for
you know it costs a lot of money to make
movies so when we say something like one
million dollars you just need to
understand that that's not a lot of
money in the
in the uh the movie world but you can
that's a sub 1 million dollar movie
right there
all right i definitely remember when we
came up with the idea to come up with an
idea for our christmas movie i still
believe we were surfing
and then we went to that restaurant that
overlooked the surf
and it was and i had on the old days i
don't know winter coat
and my swim trunks and we sat out there
and we're like
we can sit here and come up with a
christmas movie idea yeah
and we came up with the perfect gift at
a loss
as to what to get his wife for christmas
a man takes the advice
of his 12 year old step-daughter and
uses a service
that claims to select the perfect gift
for someone by analyzing their dna
hey i'm hooked when it turns out that
the gift is in fact
too perfect the man finds himself going
to extremes to get his wife back
yeah and get that one got a little fuzzy
for me well if i recall this one
correctly because
i actually spent i actually spent way
too much time
on a write-up on this one that i thought
that i remember
then stevie ripped the shreds i think
no see now you're going to throw stevie
under the bus hey i agreed with her
yeah this is not let me just unders let
me just this is not a
oh that scared the crap out of me i
thought it was stevie under the table
but it was your freaking
i i have no problems with
being told that something is not a great
idea and just because
we can make it sound like it's a good
idea some of you guys
doesn't mean that it's a good idea
because let me just go on and tell you
that
what ended up happening in this movie
was
he gets his wife a power drill and yeah
it got
really weird and it's like well he got
his wife
a power drill and it's like she's never
been into like
anything related to like fixing things
up she you know this is totally out of
not because she's a woman or any sexist
reason just because of who she is as an
individual but there wasn't there was
irony in the fact that
she was a woman who was suddenly into a
power drill which i i
understand oh she was into it that's
right she was so into it that she
becomes obsessed with the power drill
and basically it's kind of a phallic
symbol
she doesn't have sex with a power drill
but she becomes
so in love with the power drill and
using it that she's screwing
everything with this power drill and
drilling everything
and it's kind of like a being john
malkovich kind of
she yeah and she becomes so obsessed
with this power drill that then he has
to go
and meet with now we would never get
jeff goldblum to play this particular
part but
we had said like jeff goldblum is this
guy who's like a fixer he's like a
problem solver now
no he he also sold he's the one who
uh told him to buy or the power drill at
first but then it works so well that he
has to go back
it's the same guy so it's not double
mumbo jumbo which i thought was that we
had just made the mistake
he goes back he goes back to the saint
to the source and to fix it
and so he gives him
a recipe for how you undo someone's love
for something and try to get them back
and it involves
uh playing a song at a certain time like
there's a weird like a scene where
they're on the beach and he brings a jam
box and he plays
take on me or something like that i
don't know it's it was a weird it's a
weird one
it it did not remain cohesive no but
sometimes you just got to keep following
you're going to be following this thing
saint rick
this is a lot easier to follow this is
basic isn't this
essentially what the santa claus is who
cares with uh
when santa decides to delegate his
christmas eve present delivery to a
collection of
regional managers yeah yeah yeah yeah
and unemployment you should
you should this one's gonna get made man
if you say this somebody's gonna make
this
one this is a good idea well you know
what we're on record
okay unemployed family man
named rick finds himself with the
responsibility of delivering president
presidents i mean presents to children
across the southern u.s so he's like
again we're going with like redneck rick
humor well yeah yeah yeah
it's a redneck santa yeah santa has
delegated his
delivery of all his presence to multiple
santas southern santa rich
and rick has been given the southeastern
united states that's pretty great man
that i still like that one man st rick
that's a good one
that's a good one all right i got us um
let's make that
let's make saint rick see that here's
the thing you say you think that when we
say that then we can just
we can't no you can't just go make it
you got to get somebody who's like
yes i think the saint rick is a great
idea for a christmas movie and i believe
that you guys
can write a great script and i'm going
to give you this money to do it
yeah i'm trying to find out let's see
and i will say while link is looking for
more ideas i will say i have found them
um
that we are actually current currently
um
just so you know we are writing a script
for for a feature we actually
we haven't we haven't well we're not
currently writing it because
we haven't broken the story out
completely but we have a
premise and we're not going to tell you
anything about the movie
but it so we are actively working on a
feature that we are excited about but
we're also working on television 19
other things
the television pilot's getting in the
way of the the movie
script and an unscripted television idea
as well
but yeah so and everything else that you
see so it's
these things we're still trying we're
throwing a lot of things at the wall and
we always have
uh all right this one's kind of like
charlie horse but totally different an
animated comedy called glondor
um okay in 1998
the then president of the united states
commissioned nasa to have a
one hour long earth tv special broadcast
into deep space
sound familiar well no this was this was
our
this is an overhanging fruit idea that
worked on the same
principle as charlie horsey but it's
animated
uh it would be a message to any alien
civilizations out there a window to life
on earth as the president called it of
course
the special included a very narrow swath
of american pop culture including
music videos from the most popular band
at the time like the backstreet boys
highlights featuring the current nba mvp
thank michael jordan clips from movies
starring the blockbuster action hero
like a bruce willis type uh pictures of
the 1998 sports illustrated swimsuit
okay so stop
remember now so they send this
compilation of all this
1998 stuff like you just said popular
athlete popular supermodel
popular musician etc and the same exact
thing that
happens in charlie horse happens an
alien civilization becomes obsessed with
these people and
comes to earth but in this version
because this is an animated show that
needs a story engine
he kidnaps this alien ruler of gondor
dale his glondorian name is
unpronounceable in earth languages sent
a team of glendorians to kidnap the
earthlings featured on the broadcast
yeah of course they're much older now
the american celebrities more than a
decade past their prime are essentially
prisoners on gondor
living in a small earth-like village the
glendoreans did the best they could
but they messed up a bunch of details
and they're forced to hang out with dale
whenever he wants
yeah they also make appearances at
important glendorian events
they're basically like the royal family
the royal family but they're old and
they can't do any of the stuff that they
used to do like
you know washed up washed up pop culture
celebrities in in the next one in the
write-up is fairview international which
became
unattended baggage and so in this
particular document
that was the second thing that we put on
here with much less fanfare is the thing
that we ended up developing
uh we also had norman normal on here
norman was a
really old animated idea we had norman
normal actually made
he actually went really far down the
rabbit hole with that because we were
working
some producers out of new zealand
or australia contacted us in our
basement
in lillington this is back in a long
time ago this was like before online
nation
just based on our videos they were like
you guys are musical
you're comedians let's let's develop
something together and we were like well
we have an idea
anybody contacts us from australia or
new zealand
we have an idea norman normal uh
norman is totally normal except for one
detail
he owns a briefcase and this is kind of
a kid's animated show
we're thinking more kids back then
norman owns a
briefcase that contains two pint-sized
superheroes
rhett and link hey guys that's us this
might seem useful until you learn that
rhett and link each have a different
superpower
every single time norman opens the
briefcase so
so norman would be dealing with the
everyday
he was a landlord of an apartment
building and so he had like
normal not sensational but just normal
problems you know like oh there's a
flooded there's a flooded pipe in this
apartment complex and so he would open
up the briefcase
and would have one superpower and link
would have another super power but it
might be something stupid like well
rhett can grow
can shoot spaghetti out of his butthole
and link is invisible
so it's like okay what can i do with
spaghetti and somebody i can't see and
then he would close it and open it
immediately it would be two completely
new
novel superpowers and he would do that
until he got to superpowers that would
help him with his
mundane normal problem right and
the cool thing was we we were we pitched
this and
they were like we like it well let's do
something with it
and he said if you don't mind i could
take a stab at
writing starting the pilot and remember
because they had written some stuff they
had some they had produced some stuff
i think it was on like australian
television yeah i don't remember many
details so we kind of trusted them
and the dude wrote a pilot and it was
we were kind of blown away we were like
this is crazy do you have a copy of that
i i i'll look for it why didn't anything
happen with that
because i think we got cold feet let's
see if there's anything
nope don't have anything earlier because
i wasn't using i didn't move it to my
google drive
i could probably find it it might be on
my dropbox i mean
we've got some unscripted ideas i don't
want to go through those because they're
more recent they're based off of like
spinning off ideas from good mythical
mourning into their own
shows that we would host um
that's when guesstimators came back as
the show we were calling the magic
number
um norman normal draft 1.6
doc oh you found it episode
okay opening title montage montage would
be shot is an action hero
show open from the 70s but slowly
anticlimactic
showing anticlimactic events that's
great norman is doing very mundane
everyday activities from brushing his
teeth to minor repairs around the
apartment block
rhett link are singing the opening theme
each of norman's mundane tasks
ends with a superpower moment mostly
bringing a smile
to the situation in a quick cut to retin
link performing to acknowledge the
origin of the superpowers
this seems like oh yeah written by
andrew horn shout out to andrew thanks
for believing us
in us back in the day i mean there's
other stuff we can unearth maybe we'll
do that at another time but like that's
pretty much everything that i had
unearthed that i wanted to talk about
i mean i definitely remember going in
for the pitches and i do think like you
said
we can talk more about like what's the
psychological
impact on cr on
people who have all these creative
aspirations like
and being rejected so many times i mean
and sometimes things get really far like
with legitimate we were sitting in a
room at
abc network singing a song singing
this song and they like all clapped
afterward it was like
yeah it was good we were like that was
amazing we sang we nailed this song we
were talking about how jack black was
gonna die
and they were eating it up and then
nothing well okay so i
i propose that that we pick up we talk
more about the
the existential crisis of rejection yeah
i think
that you know in the next yeah so we'll
take the next episode to talk about what
experiencing that level and that amount
of rejection has
has done and what and how that might
relate to you and the things that you're
trying to do
i will say that uh we live in a weird
um we kind of have a unique situation
because
again everything that we just talked to
you about is something that a very small
until now
a very small group of people knew about
and they all had mostly
you know said no we're not interested in
this but at the same time
we've been able to have enough things
work to be able to make a living in the
entertainment industry in a very sort of
non-traditional sort of figure it out as
you go a long way through
the digital media and youtube and so it
creates this
lots of success that's sort of fueling
the growth of our company
and being able to have the margin to
develop these these traditional ideas
and to get like what you know might you
you might call you know
rewarded and to be sort of accepted
by this group of people who have decided
that they like the things that we create
that have made
it into the world but at the same time
to have this very long
string of these things that we're super
passionate about that we're very excited
about that we're always thinking about
and always trying to develop
repeatedly told no about those things
it's there's a i mean
again what i'm saying is that some
people are just getting told no
all the time right you're classic like
starving artist who
hasn't had anything work and is just
being told no and they may be super
talented and may have great ideas
we have the privilege of having had
success in this one area that gives us
the margin to be able to
develop these things and then actually
have somebody listen to them
and then be told no but it is an
interesting thing that like what is it
done
to be told no that many times and why do
we keep going right back to the drawing
board
and believing that we are going to be
able to make something like one of these
things that we
that we talked about we'll talk about
that uh next week
but for now hashtag your biscuits if any
i mean
if you love any of those and you want to
buy them if you're a network executive
hey hashtag your biscuits
and i've got a quick wreck that ties
directly into
this conversation and especially begins
to bleed over into the conversation that
we'll have
next week which is something i've been
thinking about a lot um
it's a book that's a very quick read
very easy read
called big magic by elizabeth gilbert
now elizabeth gilbert is the novelist
who wrote eat pray love which i have to
say i have not
read the book or seen the movie me
neither um
and but my wife was listening to or
reading this book
and then she was like i think you might
enjoy this book it's like it's all about
it's a non-fiction book and it's all
about the creative process and sort of
the approach to creativity i mean one of
the most helpful books that i ever read
in terms of creativity was the artist's
way right which i recommend to any
creative people
uh and i think that big magic is
you know it's similar in that it is
super inspirational
and encouraging to you as a creative
person and i think one of the points
that she makes is that everyone is
creative you don't have to be a
professional creative person to be
creative and you don't have to be a
professional creative person to
create things and to find to live a
creative life as she says
anyway um there's a few things in there
that you
it we're like okay i don't know if i
believe
fully all the things that you're saying
in some of the in some of the things
that you know there's
sort of a super spiritual side to the
whole thing but i think regardless of
where you kind of come down on that
particular
aspect of it it's one of the most
encouraging books
and it's interesting that you know we we
just went through all these these
these projects and we're talking about
failure in the next episode because
she tells so many stories about
how to get through that
rejection and people not believing in
you and how so easily you can let those
external expectations that you tie to
your work
bring you down and keep you from getting
through to the next idea and just the
nature of ideas anyway
highly recommend it for anybody who even
considers themselves even possibly a
little bit
creative big magic we'll talk at you
next week
until then a little magic to watch more
ear biscuits click on the playlist on
the right to watch the previous episode
of your biscuits click on the playlist
to the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon
to subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best